[MUSIC]
The Georgia Tech OMSCS program
launched in January of 2014,
with the ultimate goal of creating
a more accessible master's program.
We wanted everyone who wants and
deserves a Georgia Tech master's
in CS to be able to get one.
We wanted to tear down the obstacles
that usually prevent people
from participating in
a program like this one.
And this program has really
allowed us to do so.
We've removed the obstacle of geography.
We have students from every state and
from 77 different countries.
We've removed the obstacle
of availability.
Most of our students are completely
the program while still holding down
full time jobs and managing their
families and other obligations.
We've removed the obstacle of capacity,
our online classes can hold far more
students than we could
ever handle in person.
And perhaps most importantly, we've
greatly reduced the obstacle of cost.
This program costs a fraction of the
amount of traditional on-campus program.
>> I actually live here in Atlanta, and
I work just a couple
of blocks from campus.
I participate in the online program
because of all of these benefits, it's
much more affordable than a traditional
on-campus program and more importantly,
I don't have to take two years off
of work to get a master's here.
>> We've made enormous efforts to make
this program accessible because we
wanted to reach a broader
audience of students.
But in making the program accessible,
something interesting has happened.
Because you can complete the program,
without taking time off work,
it's attracted executives, scientists,
people in incredibly prominent positions
in research and
industry from around the world.
Because the cost of the program is so
low, it's attracted people that don't
view the program simply
as a career investment.
It attracts people who are here
solely because they love to learn.
And because we can take a much
larger number of students,
the program has attracted an incredibly
diverse population of people.
>From career programmers to people
working in completely different domains,
who think that Java is
coffee from Indonesia and
python is a snake in Africa.
The accessibility of this program has
allowed it to attract an incredible
population of students.
And it's the student ownership and
investment into the program that has
truly made it something special.
I love my job because I get to work
with some of the most engaged, curious,
and passionate students I've ever met.
And they'll be your classmates.
In the OMSCS program,
you'll quite likely learn more from
each other than you ever will from us.
And that's what makes this
program truly special.